nice to be watched  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  from a moment Nicolas thoughts began to  be consecutive she knew two strange  things I've always known what was going  to happen next second was that she must  never tell anyone about the first hers  was a specific kind of fortune-telling  Nicola saw the death of many many things  she knew her young friend Dominique  would fall to her death how painful I  was prepared for mom and dad  she knew her parents would die in a  plane crash both died together as I  always knew they would so why love  anyone  I met the surviving pilot and slept with  him the crash didn't kill him  love would she saw the circles of  concentric devastation with London like  a bull's-eye in the center of the board  she knew that was coming  Nicola knew when her own story ended to  some minutes after midnight on her 30th  birthday Guy Fawkes Day  for final entry in the black cross  father I found my murderer I found my  murderer I met him today  [Music]